[موسيقى]
جريمه جديده في جنح الظلام وحدات خاصه
اسرائيليه تسلل افرادها الى مستشفى ابن
سينا في مدينه جنين متنكرين بزي الاطباء
واغتالوا ثلاثه
شبان اثناء عمليه الانسحاب فضح امر الوحده
الخاصه فهب فريق ثاني لنجدتها ما ادى
لاكتشاف
امرها جرى تبادل لاطلاق النار قبل ان
تتمكن من الانسحاب
محمد جلامه قائد كتائب الشهيد عز الدين
القسام في جنين والشقيق محمد وباسل غزاوي
من كتيبه جنين سرايا القدس كانوا هدفا
للوحده الخاصه
الاسرائيليه في هذه الغرفه تم تصفيتهم بدم
بارد علما ان باسل مصاب منذ اشهر بشلل
النصفي ويتلقى العلاج بعد استهدافه بطائره
مسيره خلال اقتحام الاحتلال مدينه ومخيم
جنين 25 ع فطنا المستشفى وكل ضبيت بالمت
عليهم شي
الحكوم في بيان مشترك لكتائب القسام
وسرايا القدس اكد الفصان ان ما وصفاه
بعمليه الاغتيال الجبانه لن تمر دون رد
وان الاحتلال سيدفع الثمن لارتكابه هذه
الجريمه بينما اعتبرت اداره مستشفى ابن
سينا ان هذا الاقتحام يعد سابقه خطيره
وفصلا جديدا من فصول الاستهدافات
المتصاعده للمؤسسات الطبيه وللمرضى داخلها
يعني اجمالا هي الفتره الاخيره الاشهر
وبالتحديد الاسابيع الاخيره كان هنالك
مضايقات وتضييق كبيره على الكوادر الطبيه
وعلى المستشفيات من ناحيه محاصره من ناحيه
التعرض لل
اسعاف برضه للطواقم الطبيه والطواقم
الهلال الاحمر وك وبما انه لم يكن هنالك
رادع كان من المتوقع انه ها الاعتداءات
تزيد لكن ما تخيل ان يكون انه يتم
تصفيه يعني هي سابقه ان يتم تصفيه
ثلاثه شهداء من ضمنهم مريض يتلقى العلاج
على سره العلاج ووسط اجواء من الغضب
والحزن الشديدين شيعت جثامين الشهداء
الثلاثه نحو مقبره الشهداء في المخيم
ليرتفع عدد الشهداء منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الى
381 بفعل اقتحامات الاحتلال واعتداءات
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه فتح الباب امام تصعيد اسرائيلي
كبير لم يشمل المدن والمخيمات فحسب بل وصل
لحد كسر الخطوط الحمراء باقتحام
المستشفيات واطلاق النار كسابقه خطيره من
شانها تفجير الاوضاع الميدانيه بالضفه
الغربيه ليث جعار الجزيره جنين
فلسطين